hello, how are you, andrés gonzález
with regards to the information for thursday
, october 7, today governor styps
made the ctc will update
the positive cases of food in
lara state in a press conference
starting at three in the afternoon and
will be accompanied by members of
fema in early july nevada was
one of the first to take advantage
of fema's help for
vaccination clinics among other efforts to
mitigate the virus the governor will provide us with
the latest information
regarding contagion in the state  after a
recent report of being at the
most moderate level
there is more favorable news
the new figures of people
applying for unemployment were released for the first time in
several weeks
jobless claims fell nationally it
is about 38,000 they also
fell in the  snowy state for over
1700 dreams kicks off the season in
summerlin today official
announcement  they said yesterday that they will continue with the
golf tournament in las vegas' at least in the
near future think about extending
this competition here for at least
another five years
and now we turn to see the weather forecast
we will have cloudy skies with
winds in the valley  and we will reach a
maximum of 85 degrees as of
tomorrow the temperatures will drop and we
will remain in the 70s so put
on your coat because the cold is coming
for next week the maximum temperatures will
reach 68 degrees nice
day 3 gonzález greet you this was
about the news on snow in
Spanish
[Music]